[Music]
quantum field theory
i like to think of it as the language of
physics we use it to describe the
elementary particles
and the forces between them we use it to
describe properties of materials
phases of materials phase transitions
between them
we do to describe cosmology the
expanding universe the theory of
inflation
and most importantly we use it in the
context of quantum gravity and string
theory
where quantum field theory appears in
many different
places so it appears to be central not
only
in string theory but in all of physics
for this reason it is very important
very central and very exciting
mathematics is essential in describing
nature we have seen that over the last
century if not millennia physics uses
mathematics this has also been the case
for centuries and mathematics is central
in quantum field theory at the same time
quantum filter is not mathematically
rigorous
these are the hallmarks of a topic where
we are at the forefront of research
mathematicians appreciate that there's
something very deep going on here
because quantum field theory has had a
lot of impact on mathematics
but at the same time mathematicians are
very interested in the fact that there
is this machine quantum field theory
that keeps producing new results in
mathematics
this machine is not yet rigorous
from my own perspective mathematicians
should view it as a challenge to make it
more rigorous
but also at the same time it's an
opportunity because making it more
rigorous
will certainly lead to new ideas
we shouldn't think of it as two separate
disciplines
math and physics but there is one
intellectual
structure that all of us would like to
understand and one day we'll understand
that intellectual structure
what will quantum field theory lead to
what will it encompass
the quick answer is it i do not know
it's common in research
that we don't know what we will find
that's what makes research so exciting
if we knew what it would find it would
not be research and it would not be that
interesting
most interesting discoveries over the
last several centuries
were totally unexpected and that's what
made them
interesting and exciting i believe the
same will be
will happen here